ce matin yvelines environnement a réuni
ses partenaires pour annoncer le
lancement de son jeu concours pour
participer les enfants de 3 à 15 ans
devons remplir une grille de mots
croisés et réaliser un dessin avant le 6
avril l'association souhaite mettre en
avant le thème choisi cette année les
pollinisateurs
aujourd'hui tout ce qui tourne autour de
la pollinisation et de l'insecte
pollinisateur est extrêmement alarmant
puisque si nous ne pouvons pas si nous
ne prenons pas soin de nos insectes
pollinisateurs la pollinisation ne se
fera plus donc plus de fruits et donc
effectivement un problème pour pour
l'humanité entière le concours est
également proposée au sein des écoles
foyers d'hébergement et accueils de
loisirs yvelinois les professeurs et
éducateurs se serviront de ce jeu comme
support pour faire découvrir la nature
aux jeunes il est important de
reconnecter nos enfants à la nature par
quelques bien que ce soir alors si ce
jeu peut le permettre et bien c'est
extraordinaire les gagnants remporteront
des visites sur des thématiques
environnementales
la remise des prix aura lieu au palais
des congrès le 17 mai prochain